okay guys so what's the big difference
and how you feel being in the jury and
being in the house it's relaxing not
having your I know Ryan said this sort
of thing to like not having your head
constantly spinning and speculating and
all that stuff and be able to just kind
of like let it sort of just everything
breathe for a second it's really nice
yeah having conversations be candid is a
big change yeah having everybody explain
their decisions and their game and
everything else has been really kind of
refreshing as opposed to not knowing
whether or not they're giving you
accurate information or if they're just
trying to steer you in a particular
direction it's been nice even if like
everyone can just speak candidly about
their position and even if they saw
something differently than you did it's
nice to just be able to air it out and
figure out where everyone kind of stood
at certain points yeah so given the the
nature of unwinding after the madness
that was being in the house what are the
relationships like between you guys
currently amicable for sure everyone
gets along there are moments of course
and I think everyone's still sort of
decompressing and there's moments where
it feels like it needs to be like almost
competitive still I guess you probably
experience that more than I do where
discussions still get heated but I think
a lot of that has to do with how people
are feeling about mistakes they made
that led them here rather than kind of
actual heated conversations between
people right you know I it's if it is
what it is but we're coming at one
another from a place of more of well if
I had done this differently than you
would have done that differently and
will no I wouldn't of them and there are
things that those conversations on a
personal level now that we know that we
don't need to withhold anything about
ourselves it's nice the candid you know
it's just not about game we can actually
be like our full selves with each other
now which adds to the kind of like the
friendship level of everything so you're
carrying some game baggage with you
obviously into the jury but you know you
just mentioned now like being able to be
open and and beyond the friendship but
were you learning about each other that
you had to hide from each other before
uh I think it's different
person I think different people were
more forth company for sorry more
forthcoming about themselves I don't
know like learning to the degree that
people are superfan for example some
people kept that in yeah maddie is way
deeper into the game and she admitted
not to me inside the house but I think I
think the house magnifies who you are as
a person so there's not a lot of
personality changes for the people in
here some of the small details I think
change but not a lot of who you were and
who you are and I think it's the jury
has not been a bad group of people to be
with there were all people I got along
with in the house and so I don't mind
living with them again it's fun are you
having any sort of regrets about any
moments and gameplay that you had with
people that are currently in the house
that you're sussing out now that you're
here um or just like what Ryan said like
if that would have happened maybe this
would have happened like lots of
speculation on if you know different
Forks in the road were taken with full
regrets I'm sure that each of us have a
handful but nothing so serious as if I'm
you know plagued all the time about my
decisions at least that's speaking for
me personally and as the guy who spent
the longest amount of time here I'm just
able to snipe in from the outside and
say well you should have kept me just
kind of wander by a conversation and
throw that in so I mean you know I
obviously I have regrets in the game and
how the game turned out for me but
there's nothing that any of the people
in the house I couldn't have done
anything differently with them because
they all lasted longer than I did so
there were decisions that I made earlier
in the game that that I regret but all
of those were earlier in the game and
and had nothing to do with the people
that are coming in now right so what
kind of a juror are you gonna be come
the actual decision-making time is it
going to be are you gonna be emotional
or you gonna be thinking more game play
or something be personal you start well
I think for me there is personally
someone I can't vote for there is
somebody on remaining in the three that
I would never cast my vote for for any
reason
but of the remaining two it's a lot
easier for me to be able to say that not
just because I don't particularly care
for one person in the house but in
addition I also feel like that person
played a subpar game versus the other
two options so it is going to be a
difficult decision for me if the two
people I would vote for are sitting
there on finale night if not then it
becomes very easy for me to do but I
think from from a game point standpoint
it made it a lot easier for me with this
particular group of three to be able to
say yep there's one person I won't vote
for and the other two would get my vote
it makes sense I played this so much
more of an emotional game than I ever
expected so I think that now that I've
had time to be separate from the actual
like environment that made me so
emotional it's easier to say and to
believe that although my experience in
the game will play into my decision
which was an emotional experience I
think I owe to myself the gamer the
juror but most of all the fan to vote
with my head and not necessarily my
heart but like I said the experience was
emotional and that will play into it but
I think it'll be a very level-headed
decision that I make based on what they
tell us they could still you know
there's still game that's being played
right now right like looking at the
landscape right now before getting into
it you know going further who are you
voting for who you absolutely not voting
for and you can be as emotional as you
want what do you think I'm not voting
for Caleb there's no reason I would ever
vote for Kayla I think that in and like
I said because I believe that you are in
the game a magnified personality of who
you are outside the game the story she
told me about her outside life leave me
lead me to believe that she's a mean
person and I'm not interested in
rewarding them yeah and and I feel like
she played the game pretty sloppily as
well she got to the end and I can't take
anything away from the fact that she got
there and that there were strategies
involved that got her there but I think
that she played the game sloppily so
it's gonna be pretty easy for me not to
vote for Kayla on a personal level I'd
vote for Parris if she's sitting there
and
and Derek if she's not Paris I had a
real connection with her and her social
game from talking to everybody that's
come in the door from the jury her
social game was far and away the best in
the house this season and so it's no
it's no skin off my back to to award her
the money yeah I think less you know my
big brother brain still kicks in and
says don't commit to an answer because
if you go back on it that's bad right
now as a but Ryan said I mean well came
in with information as well as being a
jury member right so him letting us know
that Paris was able to win that final
four HOH and sort of you know solidify
her position with a win as well as her
good social game even though of course
personally I was Pro Paris all the way I
love that girl but now that actually
gives her so much more just like you
know weight to her game to me so a few
were asking me today I feel like I'd be
leaning towards Paris but once again
things can change it can be a different
set of people I would like to say that
there's not anyone I wouldn't vote for
but from my experience so far and what I
continue to hear would be difficult to
cast gala vote for similar reasons to
what what Ryan said a little bit sloppy
or anything right so diplomatic yeah you
know what is Paris gotta do what you
gotta do to get between those two
explain herself that's all if she can
figure out an articulate way to get it
out there and to explain you know I did
have relationships with everyone in the
jury but there was an expiry date to
them I got myself here with the help it
took a village but I succeeded beyond
you because of these reasons I think
that that's what the jury wants to hear
from discussing with them and for me
personally I want to hear that as well
she has to have the self-awareness to
carry her incredible game that we see
like she has to be able to convey that
to us ideal is obviously been formidable
in the house game itself are they the
real deal is a real deal with
relationship
no no I think I think I are impression
of it is that it may be for Kayla and it
certainly is not for Daryl yes and and I
think Kayla could have cut Derek twice
already and didn't which is another
detriment to her game in fact it
you took will who any of the three of
them would have won against will will
should have gotten 20 grand as a second
place finisher this season because
everybody could have beat will the fact
that she left Derek in the game and took
will out of it again is because she
believes the relationship is more than
it is I think that although there is
merit to all that stuff and I do like I
agree with a lot of it I think that
kayla has and I'm gonna use the word
romanticized because I do feel like
that's truly what it is romanticize the
idea of a dramatic final three cut my
conversations with her would be you know
productive productive up to the idea of
cutting dare but she goes nope not until
final three and I'm like but why like it
doesn't make sense to me seize the
moment I think that she's just got into
her head and romanticized the idea of
Derek romanticized the idea of their
showmance and then again the moment
where we saw you know so many other
couples I can't take you oh my god it's
heartbreaking she wants that moment and
that's where she sees her showmance
where as our perspective on it is
entirely different yeah you're saying
she's trying to write a narrative rather
than play the game at this point I think
that Derek understands that and he's
feeding into her narrative which to me
is extremely impressive mm-hmm
when you're discussing amongst
yourselves like gameplay that's happened
gameplay that's past yeah what is like
you know unanimously the most
dunderheaded moves that you guys can
think of that have happened over this
well Kayla's moves for sure this
opportunity you have to cut down not
cutting Derek twice well is offered a
perspective that maybe we needed to hear
but when it came to throwing that veto
competition when he did look so solid of
course I saw it firsthand they saw the
video that was something that we spoke
of too because it's you know guaranteed
Final Four instead of a probably gonna
go to Final Four according to somebody
else's agenda true but then again he
didn't offer a separate perspective so
those are the kind of moves that all of
us were like hitting our heads about
like why but then again maybe it was a
different perspective we haven't thought
of until we hear from them
malee sending me home that's a pretty
big mistake I mean she was the next one
out the door so yeah I guess that one
that one play-doh just later I mean I
can't it's acting me shouldn't have done
it